-You know, we don't always
have enough time
to cover everything
in the recent news,
so, here with a recap is one
of our writers, Amber Ruffin,
with a segment we call
"Amber Says What"!
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
-You guys!
The last couple months
have been crazy!
Okay, so, first of all,
Donald Trump went
to the World Series
and got booed!
And I was like, "What?!"
[ Laughter ]
Then, he went to a UFC fight
and also got booed and I was
like, [laughing] "What?!"
[ Laughter ]
Then, during his book tour,
Donald Trump Jr. got
booed offstage
and I was like,
[laughing] "What?!"
[ Laughter ]
I didn't know gettin' booed
was hereditary.
[ Laughter ]
So, then, everyone was like,
"Have you seen Cinder-Block?"
And I was like, "What?
I don't watch wrestling."
Then, they were like,
"It's a cat."
And I was like, "What?!
Why would you name a cat
Cinder-Block?"
And they showed me a picture
and I was like, "What?!"
[ Laughter, awws ]
That is a cinder block
with whiskers.
[ Laughter ]
So, apparently,
this cat has gained
too much weight
and has to walk
on a treadmill in a puddle!
[ Awwing ]
I was like, "What?!"
[ Laughter ]
Look, if it gets to the point
where you have to put me
in a harness
and make me walk
on a treadmill in a puddle
as I beg you to stop,
let me die.
[ Laughter ]
Then, I read that a French lady
gave birth to a baby
at a nightclub
and I was like, "Quoi?!"
[ Laughter ]
Vous ne devriez pas accoucher
dans un club!
[ Laughter ]
But, then, I read that the baby
would have free entry for life
and I was like, "What?!
Quelle bébé cool!"
[ Laughter ]
Then, the man who wrote
the movie "Harriet,"
about Harriet Tubman,
said that a studio
executive once suggested
that Julia Roberts play her
and people were like,
"Wha-a-a-t?!"
[ Laughter ]
But I was like, "What?
Everyone should play
whoever they want."
That's why you can catch me
in "Y'all Want This Flag?
The Betsy Ross Story."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Then, there was a rally called
Black Voices for Trump --
I'm sorry. Can you not have
that like right by my head?
Lower. Lower. Even farther.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, bless your heart.
Now, there was a rally called
Black Voices for Trump
and I was like, "Wha-a-a-t?!"
If you think your
Trump-supporting relatives
are embarrassing, imagine
how embarrassed you would be
if they were Black.
[ Laughter ]
Now, I wouldn't know,
'cause I don't have any Trump
supporters in my family
dumb enough to say something.
[ Laughter ]
So, then, former quarterback
Colin Kaepernick
got invited to train
in front of coaches
to see if they wanna sign him
and I was like, "What?!...
do you need to see him
work out for?"
You know damn well that,
even if he did nothing
but eat cheeseburgers and play
Xbox for the past three years,
he's still better
than Daniel Jones.
[ Laughter, oohs ]
And that's something I overhead
one of our security guards say.
[ Laughter ]
The only thing I know
about football is that
it gives you dementia.
[ Ding! ]
[ Laughter ]
Then, White House
Advisor Stephen Miller --
you know,
the guy who's in charge
of all the terrible stuff
happening at the border? --
had a bunch of his emails leaked
and they were full
of racist stuff
and people were like,
"Wha-a-a-t?!
[ Laughter ]
I think this guy is a racist!"
And I was like, "What?!"
A teachable moment.
So, stick with me here.
[ Laughter ]
[slowly] The White House
hired Stephen Mil-ler
to be in charge of what's
happening at the bor-der.
Now, what's happening
at the bor-der
is rac-ist.
[ Laughter ]
That means that
Stephen Miller is rac-ist.
So, if you are okay with what's
happening at the bor-der,
even after reading
Miller's emails,
then you are a rac-ist.
[ Laughter and applause ]
And that's a lesson you can take
to Thanksgiving dinner.
[ Applause ]
Your racist uncle's gonna be
like, "Wha-a-a-a-a-t?!"
[ Cheering and applause ]
So, back to one.
So, remember last year,
when they came out
with the trailer
for "Sonic the Hedgehog" movie
and, when everyone saw
the creepy new version of Sonic,
they were like, "Wha-a-a-t?!"
[ Laughter ]
Well, they went back
and changed him and I saw
the new Sonic and I was like,
"Wha-a-t?!"
He looks great!
I don't even remember what
the old one looks like anymore.
Aah!
[ Laughter ]
I'm just kidding.
It lives on in my nightmares.
[ Laughter ]
Then, they put up a tree
at Rockefeller Center
and I was like,
[singsong] "Wha-a-a-t?!"
Then, they put a star
on top of the tree.
Do you know how I know?
Because I saw it from my
office window. Look!
Look, it's the
Christmas tree star.
♪ Whoa-oa ♪
♪ It's gonna take a while ♪
[ Laughter ]
♪ Step into Christmas ♪
♪ Amber Mildred Ruffin ♪
♪ Made this stuff
for Christmas ♪
♪ So quickety biscuits ♪
♪ Yay-ay-ay-ay-ay ♪
That's Christmas.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Yay!
It's Christmas!
Christmas is now.
Then, I was like, "What?!
do I have to do
to get to go up there
and get right up next to it?"
So, I asked, and they let me.
Look!
[ Laughter ]
This has been "Amber Says What"!
[ Cheering ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
♪♪
[ Whistling ]